well christian siriano he is a
world-renowned fashion designer who has
studied under the guidance guidance of
vivian westwood and alexander mcqueen
and he addressed several celebrities
like vegas headliner lady gaga zendaya
and billy porter just to name a few yeah
just a few right
he's made sure that his designs are
fitting to several body types and styles
including bridal so how would you like
to walk down the aisle wearing a
christian siri on a wedding dress better
yet what if you could win that dress for
free our senior producer natalia
malcinito got the chance to talk with
him about that and so much more
he has been in the fashion game for over
a decade and ever since he stepped on
the project runway spotlight christian
siriano continues to shine one iconic
outfit at a time what i do on the runway
is you know it really is it's exciting
it's a form of art and it's walking and
then you can live your life in it a work
of art with a twist especially in my
shows and on the runway and on the red
carpet i really want to make sure that
people see that like really cool
exciting clothes can still look great on
all these different types of bodies
bodies that he celebrates thanks to the
help of some important people in his
life i grew up and like my mom was a
curvy woman and my sister was a really
tiny little ballet dancer and i had
these two types of women around me and i
was like well they both like the same
things so i was like okay well maybe
that's something there and just like his
inclusivity in sizing christian siriano
continues to revolutionize the fashion
world especially when it comes to bridal
couture i love a traditional wedding in
a church and fabulous but i also love
that like you know we have so many
clients that are like masculine and
feminine and non-binary or they can be
men and they want to wear a gown you
know we have it all we've done pink
wedding dresses yellow wedding dresses
we've done it all and speaking of
weddings vegas is no stranger to them
over 5 million people have gotten the
chance to say i do
right here in sin city but soon thanks
to christian serbiano and fashion show
mall one lucky bride will get the chance
of a lifetime we're gonna kind of
continue the love there and auction off
a dress a free dress so i think there's
been also a lot of people that
in the pandemic wanted to get married
but couldn't afford it or couldn't
afford a beautiful you know eight ten
thousand dollar couture gown so that's
what we wanted to do and
i'm so excited to see who wins this
dress it's gonna be amazing